Once the customizations have been applied to our metahuman character in Unreal Engine,
the next step is to check that everything is working correctly.
In this section, we will test the face and body with animations to see if any additional
adjustments need to be made in order to finalize this character.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine and apply animations to the Atomic Savage character.
Inside of Unreal Engine, I'm going to navigate to our course topics folder.
And then go to the folder named Atomic S, example, anim sequence.
Inside of here, you will find a level sequence with a face and body animation that has already
been assigned to Atomic Savage.
I will double click on this to open it.
Now to view the entire face and body, we can go to perspective and select the camera named
cam01body.
And then we can play the sequence.
I'm going to stop this for a moment.
To check the face, I'm going to go here and disable the actor and sequencer.
I'm also going to disable the body animation for now.
And I'm going to go back to perspective and view this from the front view camera so that
we can see the facial features up close.
I'm going to play the sequence now.
As mentioned in the previous course, this particular stylized character's facial features
go beyond the golden triangle of the face.
And we anticipate that even though we've used DNA calibration workflows, we may still
see some breaks in the range of motion.
For example, in the eyes.
I will zoom in here and continue playing this.
We will notice some intersecting between the eyes and the eye shell shader when this character
looks left and right.
This may be due to the eyeball and eye shell geometry possibly intersecting, or the eye
joints may need to be adjusted and moved a bit.
Either way, this area may require some additional work.
Now let's test the body.
I'm going to go back to perspective and select the CAM01 body camera again.
I will go back to the start of the sequence.
And I will set the body animation track back to active and also set the actor track back
to active.
And now I will play the sequence again.
When we get to the portion of the animation where the arms are raised, I will press pause
right here.
If we look at the shoulder and neck region, we can see that this does not look correct.
Corrective poses can be created and applied to fix these problematic areas of deformation.
To demonstrate what this will look like when corrective poses are applied, I will select
the metahuman in the viewport.
In the details panel, I will select the body component.
And I will open up the body skeletal mesh.
For the post-process animation blueprint slot, I will assign the RBF correctives animation
blueprint over here.
I will save everything.
Now when we return back to the main viewport, we will see that with the corrective poses
applied, the shoulder and neck region look much better.
Another thing worth mentioning is that the body animation that has been applied to atomic
savage has been retargeted from the female medium normal body weight using IK Retargetor.
And the bone retargeting options have also been changed.
I will go to the skeletal mesh asset window again.
And inside of here, I will go to the skeleton tree panel and use the cog wheel to select
show retargeting options.
I've changed the pelvis to animation scaled.
And I've also changed the main joints from animation to skeleton while leaving the correctives
set to animation.
Now adjusting the retargeting options is helpful when retargeting animations from skeletons
that are different proportions.
Let's do a quick review of what we just covered before we move on.
To finalize customizations to the metahuman face, it is important to test the face with
animations to ensure that everything is working correctly.
Another option is to use the face control rig with a forward solve by checking each control.
Testing the face with animations can help you decide if there are any problematic areas
that may still need further adjustments.
It is worth mentioning that the customized metahuman face will continue to be compatible
with metahuman animation tool sets such as metahuman animator and live link face.
When testing customizations to the metahuman body with animations or by using the control
rig, keep in mind that if there are significant differences in the skeleton proportions from
a metahuman based skeleton, body animations may need to be retargeted.
The bone retargeting options may also need to be adjusted.
The images on the right demonstrate what the body looks like when all of the main joints
are set to animation and what it looks like when they are set to skeleton.
To adjust the bone retargeting options, go to the skeleton tree in the skeletal mesh
or animation sequence window and use the cogwheel to check on show retargeting options.
From there, change the pelvis to animation scaled and the main joints to skeleton.
Now let's move on to the last portion of our course where we will go over some final recommendations.